jelle renverser les choses aussi en
guise d'introduction
je vous emmène bizarrement sur une ligne
d'arrivée
cette ligne d'arrivée et jaune elle est
peinte de manière permanente dans le
coeur de boston chaque année depuis près
de cent vingt ans toutes celles et ceux
qui la franchise deviennent marathonien
deviennent marathonienne le marathon 42
km et 195 m qui n'a jamais rêvé un jour
ou imaginer de le courir de le parcourir
de le franchir jusqu'à la ligne
d'arrivée
moi le premier j'ai commencé à courir il
y a trente ans et très rapidement je
suis devenu marathonien je m'entraînais
m'entraîner essayer à chaque fois de
gagner du temps l'oeil sur le
chronomètre regardant chaque kilomètre
pour pouvoir franchir cette ligne
d'arrivée le plus rapidement possible
j'ai tout de suite fait des marathons
bout de quelques années et je suis
arrivé à mon meilleur temps 3 heures 38
minutes et 53 secondes ce qui reste
aujourd'hui mon meilleur temps l'oeil
sur le chronomètre l'oeil sur la ligne
d'arrivée toujours courir courir être le
plus performant possible
toujours faire la même chose mais
essayer de le faire mieux et puis au fur
et à mesure des courses je me suis
demandé si je ne me trompais pas si le
fait d'être obsédé comme ça par cette
ligne d'arrivée ne me faisais pas manqué
des choses
le sourire des ravitaillements un
gobelet tendu une pâte de fruit des
encouragements des spectateurs ou tout
simplement des coureurs peut-être
m'empêcher de comprendre ce qu'était un
marathon le marathon peut-être nous
tromper ou je me trompe et peut-être que
le secret du marathon n'est pas de
gagner du temps mais plutôt d'en perdre
d'en perdre par exemple comme un beau
matin dans un quartier du bronx à new
york au 35e kilomètre où je m'arrêtais
dont 3 4 minutes pour discuter avec
l'espèce
quatorze tous plus ou moins étonnés de
voir ce que l'on faisait de parler à des
enfants d'échanger du temps et
finalement de garder comme souvenirs sur
la ligne d'arrivée fait moment dé change
plus rien à voir avec le temps alors je
décidé de laisser ma montre dans mon sac
de courir sans chronomètre
le marathonien allait devenir
collectionneur de marathon plus rien à
voir au lieu de faire un ou deux
marathons par an comme il est d'usagé
pourquoi ne pas en faire 4 5 6 7 10 et
profiter profiter de ces instants
découvrir des pays découvrir des villes
voyager je courus ainsi comme cela
pendant plusieurs années sur tous les
continents plus ou moins sauf peut-être
l'océanie encore à chaque fois rencontré
des gens des cultures partagées avec les
personnes et se dire que ce qui comptait
n'était peut-être pas la ligne d'arrivée
mais les kilomètres partager avec les
coureurs alors pourquoi s'arrêter
puisque plus j'allonge et la distance
plus je prenais de plaisir 42km pourquoi
pas 50 ou 100 je m'attaque et donc aux
100 km la première fois ce fut un échec
un abandon lamentable au bout de 50 km
je recommençais l'année suivante
et puis ensuite toutes les années
jusqu'en faire une trentaine à peu près
de 100 kilomètres de venir sans bornard
intéressant que le marathon peut-être si
on s'intéresse au parcours
mon meilleur souvenir de 100 km ne fut
pas mon meilleur temps ce fut le jour en
2005 où je pris le départ sur la ligne
avec 80 de mes étudiants je suis
enseignant 80 de mes étudiants que mes
collègues avaient trouvé mon peu motivés
et la seule idée qui m'était venue en
textes et leur dire montrez-leur le
contraire
avec moi nous allons courir 5 km 19 ans
venant courir 100 kilomètres ensemble
aucun d'entre eux n'a fait la distance
mais certains d'entre eux trois ou
quatre sont devenu marathonien ce
jour-là partager les kilomètres partager
ce plaisir c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant sans doute que de pouvoir
battre à chaque fois des records alors
100 km ok 100 km très bien mais pourquoi
s'arrêter cours forrest cours 40 40 km
enfants et bien augmentant le temps je
me mis à courir dès 24 heures une nuit
et une journée sans dormir des 48 heures
puis des six jours et des semis
impressionnant quand on prend le temps
allonger les distances 150-200 514 km
soit l'équivalent de 12 marathon
d'affilée en ne dormant que deux ou
trois heures par nuit sur un circuit de
2 km bizarre de sortir des sentiers et
de se mettre à courir comme un hamster
dans une cage alors on ne peut pas
comprendre ce qui se passe sauf si l'on
se rend compte que pendant ses courses
les gens qui vous accompagnent sont des
coureurs qui partage les choses avec
vous et que pendant ces six jours et six
nuits où vous parcourez tous ces
marathons d'affilée vous êtes au milieu
d'une centaine de coureurs venus du
monde entier et qu'ils échangent avec
tous avec vous la journée la nuit les
rues pas une véritable aventure
et puis où enfin un beau matin en 2014
je me retrouve bizarrement sur le quai
de roscoff
entouré d'une bande de extraterrestre au
départ de la course la plus longue de
france je n'imaginais pas quelques
années avant d'être capable ne ferai ce
que de mettre un dossard la transe gaule
courir ni pas de la manche à la
méditerranée
1200 km 50 coureurs au départ ne fume
que 40 à l'arrivée 1200 km soit
l'équivalent d'un marathon et demi par
jour sans journée de repos en courant du
matin au soir
en ne dormant que quelques heures tout
ça pour essayer de partager l'aventuré
en augmentant le temps en augmentant le
plaisir en sortant des sentiers battus
alors courir comme ça des journées en
khl est entière 10h 12h cinq ou six
heures pour les premiers penser à tout
ce qui se passe observez ce paysage ce
paysage extérieur découvrir mon pays de
manière différente
alors que j'avais traversé tant de fois
en voiture ou en train sans même le voir
découvrir aussi des paysages intérieurs
réfléchir penser des heures entières à
travailler travailler ce que l'on a
envie de faire avancer à toutes sortes
de choses
le faire seul bien sûr pendant des
heures mais aussi accompagner accompagné
de gens extraordinaires une banque si de
deux types et de filles et
extraordinaire qui traversent des pays
sur des longueurs beaucoup plus
importante que moi rencontrer des
américains qui traversent les états unis
rencontrer des italiens qu'ils couvrent
de la norvège jusqu'à l'italie des
choses insensées
si on ne comprend pas la façon dont il
les aborde je cours depuis 30 ans
j'enseigne depuis presque trente ans je
suis professeur d'université
j'adore enseigner de manière normale
mes étudiants sont devant moi il
ressemble parfois à un peloton de
coureurs prennent à absorber des
kilomètres les kilomètres de chapitres
de connaissances que je vais leur donner
j'adore faire cela et puis il ya trois
ans je me suis dit pourquoi ne pas aussi
essayer de sortir du sentier sortir de
la boîte
pas seulement pour le sport mais aussi
professionnellement je dis à mes
étudiants
avez vous envie de vous chasse cours
normalement avez vous envie que je vous
envoie toutes mes connaissances toute ma
science et vous vous allez vous
entraîner comme des coureurs à prendre
prendre et essayé de répliquer ce que je
vous apprends est ce que vous allez
essayer de battre des records
18 sur 20 19 sur 20 ou alors avez vous
envie que je vous entraîne sur d'autres
chemins leur proposait donc une méthode
que j'ai appelé la classe renverser le
do it yourself
elle se résume en une seule phrase qui
les a fortement étonné d'ailleurs la
première fois je leur ai dit écoutez
c'est très simple je suis votre
professeur nous allons travailler
ensemble pendant un semestre
ma méthode est la suivante je ne fais
plus rien et vous faites tout c'est à
dire que c'est vous qui irait chercher
les informations
c'est vous qui écrirait les plans des
cours c'est vous qui écrirait des cours
c'est vous qui ferez les cours c'est
vous qui vous dispenserait les
connaissances c'est vous qui irait au
tableau c'est vous qui poseraient des
questions vous préparer les questions
les interrogations surprises l'examen
vous distribuerez les copies vous
remplirez les copies vous ramasserez les
copies vous noterez les copines et moi
je ne fais plus rien alors idée bizarre
sans doute comme celle de courir des
milliers de kilomètres mais idée qui
peut se réaliser
depuis trois ans ma classe ne ressemble
plus à une classe normale
elle ressemble à une start up en fait
nous avons travaillé de manière à
transformer le professeur ans directeur
général nous avons réuni les étudiants
par équipes comme dans le sport et nous
leur avons attribué des missions des
productions de chapitres de
connaissances et lorsque vous venez dans
ma classe
ce sont des étudiants de licence ou de
master voyez que ces étudiants
travaillent ensemble produisent ensemble
en cohésion des équipes
ils utilisent l'informatique ils
utilisent l'internet ils viennent avec
leur téléphone portable est en fait il
utilise tous les outils technologiques
qu'habituellement parfois on leur
demande de laisser l'entrée de la glace
et puis on invente des méthodes de
travail collaboratif des méthodes où ils
peuvent travailler sur des tableaux
répondre ensemble à des questions qui se
posent même et qu'elle n'est pas ma
surprise parfois que les voir tourner
autour de tableaux enrichir leur
duction un peu comme s'il faisait course
à pied sur un circuit fermé tout en
s'enrichissant les uns et des autres de
ce qu'ils produisent des méthodes de
table au tournant des qcm inversée des
qcm intelligent on utilise des serious
games bref tout ce qui peut être imaginé
pour favoriser la pédagogie aussi je
leur dis parfois vous savez que la
meilleure façon d'apprendre c'est
d'enseigner
c'est peut-être pour ça que je suis bon
en biologie puisque la meilleure façon
d'apprendre c'est l'enseigné fait mon
cours je deviens le seul élève de la
classe
enseigner moi ce que vous trouvez ce que
vous écrivez ce que vous avez compris
alors les étudiants vont au tableau sur
des murs ils enseignent à leurs
professeurs ce qu'ils trouvent moi je
leur pose des questions des autres
étudiants sont autour de moi
nous avons renversé la classe c'est un
changement de posture
nous avons osé prendre des risques
et puis il faut aller jusqu'au bout
puisque je suis le seul élève je suis le
seul à avoir des devoirs quand je rentre
chez moi je n'ai plus de copies à
corriger
les étudiants me donne du travail et je
répond à leurs questions ils menottes
ma note si les questions sont
suffisamment travaillé je réponds bien
et j'ai de bonnes notes
si les questions ne sont pas
suffisamment travaillé si je sens que le
travail n'est pas effectif
je réponds ce que je peux j'ai de très
mauvaises notes îles mayotte méchamment
mais ils doivent nous donner les
corrections de comme il me corrige
finalement le travail est fait quand on
leur pose la question d'ailleurs ils me
disent c'est très difficile de noter un
professeur de lui poser des questions
parce que vous êtes obligés de connaître
de cours est donc finalement la méthode
fonctionne est-ce qu'elle fonctionne
vraiment je ne sais pas à voir elle n'a
que trois ans tout ce que je sais c'est
que j'observe des comportements
particuliers à relationnel différents
comme dans un sport d'équipé des
étudiants qui interrogent leurs
professeurs et puis des fois parfois
bizarrement des étudiants qui font des
selles fille à la fin du cours
devant leur production chose qu'il
n'arrivait jamais lorsque j'enseignais
normalement exactement comme il m'arrive
aussi les choses bizarres
que je ne cours plus normal alors s'il
fallait conclure s'il fallait finir
j'aimerais peut-être vous suggérer
quelque chose vous mettre une petite
idée dans votre tête de manière à ce que
vous puissiez sortir de votre coquille
si ce n'est déjà fait j'aimerais que
vous pensiez à quelque chose que vous
avez envie de faire peut-être à des
projets peut-être à des façons dont vous
travaillez peut-être à des façons dont
vous essayer d'être plus performants et
de vous inciter à sortir un peu à sortir
des chemins tracés essayé peut-être
parfois d'inverser de renverser de faire
davantage confiance peut-être de prendre
des risques mais de vous rendre compte
en reprenant ces risques vous allez
peut-être parcourir des chemins avec des
gens dont les rapports seront différents
vis-à-vis de vous dont la conclusion est
peut-être rien ne sert de courir
je vous invite à profiter des chemins